vamos a fijarnos en las dos con
formaciones más importantes del ciclo
hexano que de hecho vamos a llamar
conformación silla y conformación bote
así que aquí tengo la estructura de
puntos del ciclo hexano y estoy
mostrando los hidrógenos utilizando el
sistema de cuña y línea punteada muy
bien entonces si dijera que este de aquí
por ejemplo es el carbono 1 el carbono 2
3 4 5 y este último es el carbono 6
porque entonces si nos fijamos en esos 6
carbonos parece que se encuentran en el
mismo plano verdad vemos un hexágono
todo esto sería un hexágono que se
encuentra en el mismo plano ok
en realidad eso es lo que parece pero
pero no es realmente la conformación más
estable para el ciclo hexano en realidad
una conforman la conformación más
estable del ciclo hexano es esta
molécula que se encuentra aquí abajo que
se le conoce como la conformación silla
y algunos estudiantes muchas veces se
confunden de porque se les dice con
formación silla así que si esta
conformación la gira son un poquito
vemos es algo así más o menos más o
menos entonces puedes ver que es una
especie como de silla o quizás puedes
ver como como uno de estos camastros que
se encuentran afuera de las de las
albercas en donde en esta parte pones tu
cabeza en esta parte pues pones tu
cuerpo y aquí van las piernas verdad
entonces por eso es la conformación
silla
ahora vamos a seguir y vamos a enumerar
los carbonos en esta estructura como lo
hicimos en la anterior así que digamos
que este es el carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y aquí
tenemos nuestro último carbono el
carbono 6 y podríamos pensar que estos
carbonos no son planos verdad de hecho
se encuentran algunos más arriba o más
abajo respecto a los otros verdad y esto
es más fácil de ver si o si por ejemplo
tienes un modelo molecular y empiezas a
girar lo ya ya ya observarlo tú mismo en
tres dimensiones ahora vamos a ver que
se encuentra atado al carbono número uno
y podemos ver que hacia arriba del
carbono 1 verdad si éste se encontrará
en el plano vemos que hacia arriba se
encuentra un hidrógeno entonces este
hidrógeno corresponde al al que se
encuentra por arriba del plano digamos
en donde se encuentran estos 6 átomos de
carbono verdad y si nos damos cuenta en
cualquiera de estos carbonos tenemos ese
hidrógeno que sale hacia arriba
acaso irá hacia abajo verdad por ejemplo
aquí va a ir hacia abajo acá va a ir
hacia arriba acá va hacia abajo acá va
hacia arriba y aquí va hacia abajo
verdad entonces realmente estos
hidrógenos que acabo de dibujar son los
que se conocen como los hidrógenos
axiales ok son justamente los que van
completamente hacia arriba o
completamente hacia abajo a partir de
cada carbono lo cual define justamente
como como un eje verdad
ahora bien los otros hidrógenos por
ejemplo este de aquí serían los
hidrógenos ecuatoriales esos les vamos a
conocer como hidrógenos ecuatoriales muy
bien y como me gusta pensar es
justamente como si fuera el ecuador
verdad así que en el carbono 1 este es
nuestro hidrógeno ecuatorial que si va
para abajo el que sigue en el carbono 2
irá un poco hacia arriba en el tercero
irá hacia abajo en el cuarto hacia
arriba en el quinto hacia abajo y en el
sexto hacia arriba entonces puedes
observar este patrón para los axiales
hilos ecuatoriales que van alternando si
van hacia arriba o hacia abajo entonces
ahí ya tenemos nuestra conformación de
tipo silla para el ciclo externo ahora
vamos a fijarnos en la proyección de
newman para para la conformación silla y
chequeamos la estabilidad de nuestra
molécula ok entonces primero tenemos que
definir un punto de perspectiva desde el
cual vamos a estar observando y en
realidad vamos a estar observando
desde acá vamos a poner nuestro ojito y
si nos damos cuenta el 3 está en el
mismo eje que el carbono 2 verdad
entonces ahí tenemos
digamos nuestra perspectiva y lo mismo
va a pasar para el carbono 5 esto es lo
más importante tenemos 2 carbonos que se
están en dos pares de carbonos que se
están digamos encimando desde nuestra
perspectiva entonces vamos a poner
primero el carbono 5 que es el primero
que aparece ok este es el carbono 5 y
podemos ver que hacia arriba tenemos un
hidrógeno que es nuestro hidrógeno
axial mientras que abajo hacia la
izquierda tenemos otro hidrógeno ese es
nuestro hidrógeno ecuatorial sin embargo
hacia abajo a la derecha estamos uniendo
los aún al carbono número 4 verdad este
es nuestro carbono número 4 vamos a ver
ahora qué pasa con el carbono 3 1 con el
carbono 3 vamos a ponerlo más o menos
por aquí el carbono 3 tiene un hidrógeno
axial que va hacia arriba ahí está
axial mientras que hacia abajo a la
derecha tiene el hidrógeno ecuatorial
ahora bien hacia abajo a la izquierda
está uniéndose también al hidrógeno al
perdón al carbono 4 entonces aquí es en
donde hay una conexión entre el carbono
5 y el carbono 3 justamente a través del
carbono 4 verdad qué pasa ahora si
pintamos el carbono 6 bueno el carbono 6
está detrás del 5 entonces justamente
aquí lo pintamos como una un círculo y
nos podemos fijar que hacia abajo tiene
el hidrógeno axial
mientras que el ecuatorial está hacia la
izquierda verdad tenemos un hidrógeno
ecuatorial hacia la izquierda y hacia la
derecha estamos uniendo lo con el
carbono 1 y está el carbono 1 vamonos
ahora con el carbono 2 el carbono 2 se
encuentra atrás del carbono 3 y
nuevamente tiene un hidrógeno axial
hacia abajo un hidrógeno ecuatorial
hacia la derecha y se está uniendo al
carbono 1 entonces aquí es en donde
hacemos la conexión y ahí tenemos el
diagrama de o más bien en la proyección
de newman para la conformación silla de
nuestro ciclohexano y lo que podemos ver
es que todo está alternado verdad
entonces esto tenderá a ser muy estable
vamos ahora a fijarnos en la
conformación de bote para el ciclo
hexano y que es justamente este que puse
aquí abajo
ok ahí tenemos la conformación bote la
conformación si ya puede convertirse
digamos en la conformación bote y eso lo
cubriremos en algún vídeo posterior pero
por ahora sólo vamos a fijarnos en la
formación bote y vamos nuevamente en
humedad de los carbonos digamos cual
podríamos elegir este va a ser digamos
nuestro carbono 1 este sería nuestro
carbono 2 3 4 y 5 y finalmente 6 de
ahorita no vamos a fijarnos en qué tipo
de hidrógenos son ok no no no vamos a
enfocarnos tanto en si son axiales o
ecuatoriales sólo vamos a poner los
hidrógenos que están unidos a cada uno
de estos carbonos ok aquí está hasta
abajo este
ahí lo tienen esa es la conformación de
tipo bote y realmente creo que es
bastante inmediato de porque parece un
bote verdad aquí justamente el ciclo de
kart de los carbonos parece justamente
un barquito verdad como un barco de
papel ahora bien cuál sería la
proyección de newman necesitamos definir
dónde vamos a empezar a observar y
digamos que estamos observando desde
esta perspectiva qué es lo que va a
pasar que el 3 va o para acá va a estar
digamos enfrente del 2 y tienen más o
menos
esta línea de digamos de la perspectiva
y también va a ocurrir lo mismo con el 5
y el 6 verdad entonces de esta forma
podemos repetir la idea del ejemplo
anterior para la proyección de newman
entonces vamos a poner primero
nuevamente el 5 de este lado vamos a
poner aquí el 5 y podemos ver que hacia
arriba y hacia la izquierda tenemos un
hidrógeno un hidrógeno perdón y lo mismo
hacia abajo
entonces aquí tenemos nuestro hidrógeno
y nuestro otro hidrógeno sin embargo
hacia la derecha estamos uniendo con el
carbono 6
16 vamos a pintar ahora digamos el
carbono 3 vamos a pintar el carbono 3
y vamos a ponerlo más o menos por aquí y
podemos ver nuevamente que hacia abajo
hay un hidrógeno y hacia la derecha
verdad tenemos hacia la
no hubo un error aquí regresemos un
poquito al 5 el 5 hacia la izquierda así
está el hidrógeno y hacia abajo verdad
pero hacia la derecha no es el 6 sino se
va hacia el 4 entonces este corresponde
al 4 perdón perdón por el error y ahora
sí queda muy bien porque el 3 tenemos
que hacia la derecha verdad si lo vemos
desde esta perspectiva aparece el
hidrógeno aquí está el hidrógeno verdad
y hacia abajo también
sin embargo hacia la izquierda tenemos
que se conecta con el carbono 4 ok y ahí
es importante remarcar que este el
carbono 4 para que no hubiera ninguna
confusión muy bien entonces ahí tenemos
el carbono 5 y el 3 vamos a ver qué pasa
si pintamos el 6 el 6 se encuentra
detrás del carbono 5 entonces podremos
ponerlo como un círculo y el carbono 6
está unido hacia la izquierda también
con un hidrógeno verdad entonces estos
dos se encuentran de esta forma lo mismo
para el hidrógeno que va hacia abajo del
carbono 6 y hacia la derecha está
conectándose hacia la derecha está
conectándose con el carbono 1 muy bien
entonces tenemos el carbono 1
y ahora vamos a saltarnos al carbono 2
el carbono 2 se encuentra atrás del
carbono 3 el carbono 2 tiene hacia abajo
un hidrógeno tiene hacia la derecha otro
hidrógeno y hacia la izquierda se
conecta con el carbono 1 entonces aquí
ya tenemos nuestra proyección de newman
para la conformación bote y puedes ver
que todo está eclipsado verdad
justamente por eso es que vamos a tener
una mayor cantidad de energía por lo que
hemos visto en los vídeos anteriores
vamos a tener una mayor cantidad de
energía o de tensión torsional mientras
que en la conformación silla tenemos
menos energía y lo cual quiere decir que
es más estable
estable
y retomando un poquito la conformación
de tipo bote además de la cuestión de
que todo esté eclipsado hay algo que se
le conoce como la interacción de hasta
digamos y eso es que estos dos
hidrógenos degeneres son este hidrógeno
y este hidrógeno ok
esos dos hidrógenos se encuentran muy
cerca y por supuesto por supuesto que
eso va a desestabilizar a la
conformación también entonces no tenemos
ninguna interacción de tipo hasta con la
conformación silla y por todas estas
razones la conformación silla es la que
tiene menos energía haciéndola mucho más
estable ahora en el próximo vídeo lo que
vamos a hacer es vamos a tratar de
convertir la conformación si ya la
conformación bote y viceversa